Hello everyone
Thank you for coming to London for the Playtime Conference.
This is my first time at this conference, so I should be a rookie in this regard.
However, I have been engaged in game production for a long time.
And I also like this line myself.
I want to share with you today is one of my favorite topics.
Introduce how to attract users
Keep playing your game every day, every week, every month so that all players can’t stop
And want to experience more game content.
This is one of the topics I want to share with you most.
I am very honored to be here.
Let's discuss this topic with everyone. Thank you for coming.
In order to avoid everyone not seeing me, I will introduce myself again.
My name is Alan Gutterman.
I work for the business development team at Google Play.
Mainly responsible for game design and consulting with developers
How to promote the best game design
And best practices on the platform
Then let's get started.
This is today's topic
First, we need to define the definition of "interaction"
Because this theme is very simple and easy to understand.
But there are still some places worth clarifying
To ensure that everyone has a consistent understanding
Make sure that we are all talking about the same thing
Then we have to talk about the core part of today’s speech.
That is to design the game for the purpose of improving the degree of interaction.
We will talk about Google Play Game Services.
Just now Ben and John are very clear
Introduced this kind of service it is a game for you
Create a wonderful interactive toolbox
A variety of essential tools are basically available
Followed by the fourth theme
We are talking about the community because the community is really important.
It’s your attraction to developers, sorry, wrong.
Should be your way to engage users as a developer to interact with your game.
So what is interaction?
I think everyone in the room may know
How to measure engagement
I mean, we will see the retention rate of 1 day, 7 days, 30 days.
Through this method
We can understand how users interact with the game.
Do they love the game?
We will also look at the number of daily sessions and session duration.
In addition, we will also look at an indicator
It is similar to sticky factors
That is the ratio of the number of active users per day to the number of active users per month.
That is DAU/MAU, this is a percentage value.
But what is the nature of interaction?
We know how to measure it but what is it?
In fact, there are two types of interactions.
I want to introduce these two types of interactions.
The first is direct interaction
This is an interaction we often see.
It is also a relatively intuitive one.
Because it refers to
Someone is using games and playing games
This is a game called Two Dots.
This is the picture after I passed the 123rd level.
This is how direct interaction is very easy to understand.
Is the player directly in the game
All interactions
But there is another type of interaction that we will cover in detail later.
I will mention it a little now.
Because this interaction is also very important
I call it community interaction.
This concept can be understood in this way
Think about what your hobbies are
Very interesting is
I was thinking about this example before watching the opening video.
It was before this opening theme speech by Purnima this morning.
The opening video that was played
Let me think of this example of fishing.
Suppose there is a great fishing app.
Then this app will naturally attract
Members of the fishing enthusiast community interact with it
So this example is just right
Thanks to the coincidence
Otherwise I am afraid I can't find a better example.
The example I want to say is when I was younger.
Once I returned to my hometown of Houston, Texas.
That is the border between the Gulf of Mexico and the United States.
There is a small town called Galveston nearby.
Is a great place for fishing
One night, the night is beautiful.
So my friend and I decided to go out fishing.
So we went and caught the fish
Last 10 minutes before returning
We caught a big fish of 10 kg.
Honestly, that was the most productive night I have ever fished.
I am here to tell you this story.
Everyone started playing earlier today.
The app introduced in the video
These behaviors are social interactions
This kind of interaction means that you are not directly engaged in a hobby.
Or everything that is done with a game or this hobby
Or this game related activity
When I throw a fishing rod
Or when I play Two Dots or other games
This is direct interaction
The second type of interaction is community interaction
This kind of interaction is also important
We will explain the exact reason later.
Let's talk about the topic of "designing games for the purpose of enhancing interaction".
I have just introduced the exact definition of interaction.
Now let's talk about how to design games for this purpose.
I can cite countless games as examples.
Explain for everyone
Why are they designed to increase engagement?
But this is not very useful.
So I decided to narrow the scope to three games.
I have been playing these three games for a long time.
Their styles are very different
But their launch time is almost
Almost all launched for about a year and a half
And have very good results on Play.
One of the games is "Two Dots" Has anyone played "Two Dots" in the audience?
Please raise your hand
Ok
About half of people have played this game very well.
Another game may be a bit like the US
Called "Family Guy: Quest For Stuff"
Developed by TinyCo
People who have played, please raise your hand and have two people, not bad.
Oh, no, three people are great.
The last game is Hearthstone
Who played this game developed by Blizzard Entertainment?
Ok, let me see how many people have played with Two Dots.
awesome
These three games are very good
And the style is very different
"Two Dots" is basically
Casual games that everyone usually play
TinyCo's "Family Guy" belongs to the construction game
It is similar to the game "Sim City" which is a medium hardcore game.
The Hearthstone is
Hardcore games on the Play platform
The three games I picked
Very different in terms of game design, style and type
Let's talk about these games and their design concepts.
This is the picture of "Family Guy: Quest For Stuff"
This picture I found online
This picture clearly illustrates the game
Why can it be so popular for so long?
This is the content screen after the game is launched 1 year later.
This game has been launched for 1 and a half years.
And this is exactly the content screen when it was launched for 1 year.
This game is through the following loop mode
To operate and provide services
TinyCo releases new content
Players create these in the game
The gameplay of this build game
Similar to games like Sim City or Farmville
Players need to build content and they slowly complete the construction of these content
So they will present a variety of content in their beautiful city.
Then TinyCo will release more content.
For the player to experience and build and complete all the build work
The whole game is constantly cycling in this mode.
TinyCo must complete this cycle in a very fast pace
So the company releases new content every two weeks.
I call this model "content stove"
I didn't mean to downplay this game. I really like this game.
The so-called stove is used to burn things.
I call it the content stove.
Because TinyCo is constantly introducing new content.
Players experience this content and slowly burn it out
Just like you keep adding coal to the stove
Just to keep the fire strong
If you stop adding coal to the stove
The fire in the stove will go out
This is one way to maintain user engagement.
But this way must invest a lot of resources
And the resource consumption is also very fast
In this way, the content stove actually
Unable to expand flexibly
So I put the content stove again.
Metaphor for single player content
One item for an interaction
After experiencing an item
I can't experience it again.
Therefore, it does not improve the degree of interaction well.
So the question now is when you design the game for the purpose of improving your interaction.
How to improve the interaction when using this mode?
How can I make my own development time or development cost?
Get a higher profit?
Next
Let's take a look at the example of "Two Dots".
Because half of the people here have played this game.
So I don't need to introduce this game in detail.
However, it is still a matchmaking game for people who have never played.
But it is different from Candy Crush or Cookie Jam.
In fact, the matching game itself is very much like the content stove.
Both Cookie Jam and Candy Crush
More than 1000 levels of content are amazing
And each level has been carefully designed and measured
"Two Dots" has more than 400 levels
So it is also a content stove
The game launches a new level
The most loyal players will quickly break through
Then I started to wait for the game to launch a new level.
So definitely it’s the content stove.
But things are not over
Next is the most interesting part
Look at this again, this is the score when I broke 123.
242 points
I got a star for the top three stars.
Then there is my avatar on the leaderboard.
My friend Aaron got a higher score than me.
And my score is higher than Eric
So what can I do?
I can continue to play the 124th level.
Continue to consume game content
Because it is a content stove
But the subtlety lies in
I will replay this level under the encouragement.
In fact, this incentive comes from two aspects.
On the one hand, I want to replay this level.
To get a higher star rating
This is the incentive set by the developer.
On the other hand, I want to play again to defeat Aaron.
Let his smile face behind me
Because his smile is a bit like laughing at me to show off his high scores.
Therefore, whether it is the pursuit of personal achievement
Like getting three stars
Or hope to exceed friends' high scores
These motivations will prompt players to play the same content repeatedly.
This actually increases the level of engagement.
So from this perspective, the repetitive playability of content
Can increase engagement
This is the key
If you want your own development costs and development time
Bringing you higher returns
Repetitive playability of content is the key
Thus
What is different from what we saw in the TinyCo example is
A content is more than just an interaction but can create multiple interactions
I want to explain one thing through the last slide.
Let's go back to the previous slide.
The three stars representing achievements
Belonging to a limited achievement
Once the achievement of Samsung is achieved
I basically don't want to play this off again.
As long as I get three stars, I will be satisfied.
But look at this leaderboard again.
Suppose I actually won him in order to overplay Aaron.
I may post this message on Facebook or Twitter.
Or send an email directly or you may go to Aaron and say
Hey, man, I am over your score.
Then he may be stimulated and want to beat me.
Maybe Eric will join the battle at the time.
As a result, everyone began to compete with each other.
Then evolve into a long-term competition
In contrast, the developer is here
Set the personal achievements of the three stars
Ultimately limited in terms of increased engagement
But this kind of competition for high scores can improve game engagement endlessly.
This is why we say
Repeatable playability is actually the key to increasing engagement
In general, the competition of multiple players, or any competition
Usually allows players to interact with the game infinitely
Honestly, we can continue to compete for the highest score of this level.
Everyone saw this in the early years when game consoles were popular.
Gamers of the 80s
I like to compete for high scores in games like Pac-Man.
It’s still the same today because the game’s approach is similar.
I said before that I will talk about Hearthstone.
This is the scene of the Hearthstone Championship.
Many players gathered together to compete in the game
The scene is quite spectacular
"The Hearthstone" was released about a year and a half.
But the player’s enthusiasm for the game has not been reduced.
You may ask yourself
Should I add a multiplayer mode to the game?
Will multiplayer games be a "magic bullet"?
This is of course a good start.
What else can you do?
Let the multiplayer game successfully enter the market?
You won't say that we are going to join the multiplayer mode and see what happens.
Things are definitely not that simple
Hearthstone uses a unique method to build games
To increase user engagement
Allow many players to be in different levels
Play at different paces for everyone
Let's take a look at this game.
This is the picture I saw when I first logged into Hearthstone.
This is a daily task
I can be a mage or a shaman.
Or the identity of the paladin or samurai won two victories
After completing all these tasks
I can get all the gold coins
That is a total of 140 gold coins
These tasks are at the end of each day
That is, it will be refreshed after 24 hours.
So I can log in to the game every day.
Complete these tasks
Great design
They recently released a feature
Called "tavern chaos"
This feature has not been released when I capture this screenshot.
But I still use this screenshot
It’s convenient for me to explain the pace of the game.
Hotel chaos is a competition from Wednesday to Sunday
The system will bill the reward at the end of Sunday
And will show the player’s ranking in the tournament.
The competition is held once a week
I have to log in to the game to join the competition once the day of the week arrives.
So this type of activity is similar to the daily task mode.
Just it is once a week
This is a screenshot of the March 2015 season.
Players reach level 6 in casual mode at the top 3% of all player rankings
Someone wants to guess this is my achievement.
Or is it a screenshot of the achievements of a player I am looking for online?
This is a screenshot taken online, not mine.
I am so good, just fine.
I once played to level 10
This is the ranking of the March 2015 season.
Is the monthly ranking
Therefore, Hearthstone has a daily mission weekly tournament
There is also a monthly ranking
Do you see their strategy?
Let's see how they design this architecture.
There is a variety of multiplayer game modes in Hearthstone.
Single player mode
For example, there is a single adventure mode in the arena.
Players can play with the last progress at any time
And everyone can play
This part is content that can be played at any time.
Again, the daily task
You can get the rewards when you play the game every day.
You can also participate in the weekly competition of "Bar Fighting"
The other is the game mode designed for the core players.
Let them compete to compete for monthly rankings
Do you see any tricks?
They designed a multiplayer game
The whole game is designed in a variety of ways.
Let the player want to play how to play
Whether it is a daily task or a weekly competition
Still monthly ranking
They try their best to take care of every player.
Let players follow their own specific way
Looking for fun in the game
Whether it’s extremely casual or extremely intense or in any way between the two
I think this is really smart.
We just talked about the tasks in this game.
Also mentioned in all of these games
Multiplayer competition
Also mentioned the leaderboard
And achievement
These things sound familiar
I have just talked about all of this before.
That is the Google Play game service.
Play Game Services is a toolbox designed for developers
Assist them in developing all these great features
Make the player in the process of playing the game
Keep an interest in the game
These are the images I took from the Play Games app.
By the way, its installation has exceeded one billion.
If you have never used this app before
It may be useful to use it immediately.
This is a great app. I can use it to manage how I play games.
I am a player on this platform.
I will open this app to see the new game news.
Let's take a look at these things.
There is a leaderboard here.
This is a game I played "Threes!"
This is one of my favorite casual games
Doug is much better than me, I always win him.
I will continue to play this game under the encouragement.
Strive to exceed his score
This is another very popular game on our platform.
Called "Island"
I have completed 48% of my achievements
My progress is slow
I know that John and Ben are better than me.
Next, let me talk about the task. The example I gave is the game of PennyPop.
Called "Battle Camp"
Every time a new task is displayed in the Play Games app
I will be anxious to complete the new task.
In addition, we still have multiplayer games.
Includes time-based multiplayer and real-time multiplayer games
Allows you to compete directly with other players
This is very important
We mentioned before
How to make your development costs and time bring you the most benefit
If you like, you can build all of this content
But to be honest, Ben Frankel can help you.
Very easy to achieve this
You can use our service directly
Achievements, leaderboards or multiplayer games
All content is readily available and ready to use
This is a toolbox that can help you increase the user engagement of your game.
That's it
Let’s go back and look at this picture of Hearthstone.
This tournament looks very exciting.
Many players are actively participating
I don't know how many screens there are in total.
There are about 10
Did everyone notice it? There are many people next to you who are not playing games.
There is also a replay screen above
This tournament itself is a community interaction.
Someone is playing the game, someone is watching, and some people are talking about it.
Actually not everyone is playing games
And those who are not playing games
As we have defined before
These people are participating in community interaction
Why is community interaction so important?
You may have seen such a graph before.
This is a very typical marketing curve in Marketing 101.
Used to track the adoption of products by people over time
These objects include innovators and early adopters
Early majority, late majority and laggard
If you read Malcolm Gladwell's book
You must have seen this curve
What I want to say is
Some influential people will encourage others to download the game.
Go fishing, buy magazines or try a restaurant
These are the people who actually engage in community interaction.
They are not only influential
And they are all well-known experts.
They basically belong to this section
For any new product
They are the people who are most active to experience
And this applies to any industry
So the importance of community interaction is self-evident
People talk about your game
Post information about your game on various social media
And making a YouTube video.
Behavior like this
All belong to the category of community interaction, so community interaction is crucial
Because the community is actually
Your game’s interaction and marketing channels
So the community is very important
Currently, the cost of acquiring users is extremely high.
On our platform or most other platforms
Sometimes the cost of getting a user is more than $15.
However, community interaction can
Free new users for your game
Very incredible!
If you want to make the game attract users for a long time
And keep getting new users
This is one of the most effective methods
Finally, I want to talk a little more about social interaction.
I wish I still remember
I talked to the community administrator about this.
But the conversation is very interesting
And very important
We explored a lot today how to make the most of it.
Development costs and development time
Because our resources are limited
For the community, you can build your own community in real time.
No need for trouble engineers
Graphic designer and product manager
No need for quality assurance
No need to post a new version on Google Play
No need to go through the review process
You can develop the game at the same time
Create a community in real time
This is obvious
But also very important
Your community should be open at all times and be engaged at any time
At any time, you can engage with community members through a variety of activities.
And no need to bother the development team
Will not interfere with other progress and compete for resources
Your community manager or community team
Is completely independent
this point is very important
Regarding the community, I will add the last point.
We just discussed the online community
I showed some pictures of the Twitter feed.
Also talked about YouTube, etc.
However, the best way to interact with users
There is no one-to-one interaction with users directly in real life.
I want to take Glue as an example.
I have worked with Glu for a long time.
The two games they developed are the most popular games on our platform.
One of the games is "Racing Rivals". This is the most popular racing game on our platform.
Another game is "Kim Kardashian Hollywood"
I believe everyone is very familiar with this game.
Their community activities are quite ingenious.
Really shows what the community can bring
Powerful role
Let's take a look at Racing Rivals.
"Racing Rivals" has been available for several years.
It was originally a Facebook game that has now been turned into a mobile game.
It has a large number of players
I have been playing this game for years.
And collect the car
These players love this game for ten minutes.
They spent a lot of money in this game and actively participated in it.
As people say, this type of player is a car enthusiast.
They love cars and are addicted to this game.
When the developer is at the studio in Long Beach
When developing the next function kit
They will think
We have a group of diehard gamers.
For what we want to develop next
They should be able to make some suggestions
Because when you look at the development blueprint
You can develop with imagination
Can also follow the example of Glu
They invite 20 or 25 most loyal players
Take a flight to Long Beach
Sitting together and discussing next should be
What features are developed in Racing Rivals
They started a heated discussion about planning new features
They are equal to the community
Turn into a game designer
I promise, when these guys and girls
After flying back to my hometown
It is very likely that "Racing Rivals" will be highly recommended.
Maybe everybody will say
I personally experienced this unforgettable event.
I went to Long Beach and discussed with the Racing Rivals development team.
Help them design this game together
I dare to package tickets with everyone.
This will make these players and their friends more like this game.
The publicity effect is even more amazing
Like me, I am also promoting them now.
This is the social interaction of Racing Rivals.
Similarly, for the game "Kim Kardashian" they held a competition in the game.
And invite some of the most loyal young players in the game.
Take a flight to meet Kim
They are not discussing game design
Just held a meeting
But I promise everyone who goes to meet Kim, including me.
If everyone is interested
I can see the photos on my phone later.
I will come to me later.
I can't put these photos publicly here.
I promise everyone who attends the meeting.
Will definitely promote this game to people
This is a social activity in real life.
You can take this opportunity to talk face to face with consumers.
And listen to their feedback
This is the most effective way to promote community interaction
Will definitely return after a period of time
This is the end of my speech today.
[applause]
[play music]